you to monde squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur dead là-bas juin des comme
d'habitude new game c'est parti on y va
on va devoir un peu l'histoire
jean christophe géhin des doreurs du
moins est parfois un petit peu chelou
ouais enfin guy pleut du sens au lieu
dit merci d'être venu aujourd'hui ça va
commencer dans un instant d'accord très
bien alors 1er avril 2013 unique l'abbé
level 57 très bien dans une sorte de
dortoir oui
[ __ ] de rick est passé sur la gauche
tu m'as pas vu le losc a presque tous en
sort très bien guy hoquet vient nous
dire de prendre la langue de trouver une
armée de le rejoindre dans la security
room
écoutez je propose que déjà qu'il se
calme on n'est pas son chien et puis bah
que on sent on s'en bat les steaks et
autres couches voilà a laissé tout le
monde à broc alors musique dramatique en
fond auquel sommes trop dark
alors comme on allume c'est la touche
pour allumer la lampe très bien eh bien
on va jouer sans lampe
tout va bien à c'est par là pour cesser
le jeu d'horreur pourquoi il a du sens
dans un coin de la pièce esquelbecq
allait mourir il s'est dit je veux
mourir dans un coin de la pièce sinon
c'est peine de mort bien attention non
non et non c'est pas possible
alors comment on fait pour s'en aller
what un flop la boxe ou de merde dans
celle où presse f tout gueule flash lite
à fallait attendre d'être dans le
couloir bonjour on les rate vous arrêtez
tout de suite tout de suite
mann center très bien man center gauche
ou droite on va aller plutôt à gauche à
parce que ce quelqu'un vient de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé je suis
choqué ouah [ __ ] je rigole pour le
voir mais je sens que bientôt
ok donc voilà donc on peut prendre des
objets hop hop hop voilà parce que ce
soit on est déjà macasty ou pas
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans clochard
simulator un jeu devons chercher la clé
de la porte dans les poubelles
alors mon avis faut aller juste là haut
tout bêtement ah non non non non je
prenne une caisse on prend une caisse et
on lâche une caisse si quelqu'un a
rigolé qu'ils se manifestent
si je donne 100 euros avec le roi
dacquois bande de chiens
est ce que est ce que je pourrais
rentrer dans ce tunnel et [ __ ] ça ça
c'est genre de truc qui me rend
complètement dingue dans les jeux vidéo
déplaît à voile à la 6 place et là c'est
l'émission pour en place d'un conduit
d'aération mon jeu donc là c'est à un
autre conduit juste là parfait des
grilles est-ce qu'on peut pas passer par
cette petite porte d'or look très bien
on n'a toujours pas trouvé d'armes ce
qui ne met absolument pas vu
c'est une blague ou quoi moi ta faute
mais c'est quoi ce pistolet mon gars il
écoulé en plomb mais c'est une réplique
c'est pas du tout à mon pistolet faut
pas aller là-bas est tombé d'accord
c'est la porte du début donc on va donc
passer par la gauche et c'était fini on
pouvait se dire au revoir et fin de la
vidéo
bon alors je prends une petite gorgée 2
au parfait shoot the barrel steinbach
est ce qu'on peut être appelée sur cette
superbe explosion s'il vous plaît waouh
ça dépote à croire que cette chute
allez on lui dit tout sans boire ouais
il est tombé comme une grosse merde je
pense qu'il faut passer par là selon
bill et où il est mort al batha à l'est
pas - all bat à il doit être quelque
part poser y'a pas des munitions non à
part des bons gros instrument de torture
bien dégueulasse yade c'est what what a
voulu me faire peur je te dis pas que ça
va marcher
peut-être cette porte-là moyens aux
ailes bleues juste de faire un câlin
regarder fait un câlin ou oula oula ça
va me plaire ou lalalalalala on se met
bien je sens que le long beach est tombé
là il va venir faisant un bond à la
voile à l'apport à l'énergie est là bas
qui nous attend et ma petite demoiselle
et 360 360 tout jobs n'est pas car je
suis le à à s'il vous plaît la lampe
s'il vous plaît a atteint phoques et atx
et c'est pas du tout normal ce qui vient
de se passer là mais tu as good as gold
attends attends j'avais bien aller on ce
propos quel le côté haut
et de voir arriver à l'autre bout de
cette salle il y as flotte désormais sur
la route je cours j'espère vont sortir
en barbie pourquoi n'es tu pas sache où
et qu'on sortait ensemble s'il se fait
carrément fait beau qu'est ce qu'il ya
christian jacquet pas trop oh merde j'ai
fait un truc que j'aurai 40 pas dû faire
quoi merde
tintin tintin dans le frigo d'un frigo
on peut pas aller on va dans le mec mais
c'est qu'avoir un enfant ou quoi